joe biden is one year into his
presidency and it is a full-fledged
disaster on every single level can he
pull out of the tailspin i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the men shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment one aspect of the biden
administration that has just been
horrifying is of course the runaway
inflation brought on by his crappy
fiscal and monetary policy well you
might be thinking hey perhaps i should
diversify away from the collapsing
american dollar
and if you are thinking this you're
thinking correctly you should spend at
least a little bit of your portfolio in
precious metals and that means you
should talk to my friends over at birch
gold protect your savings right now
hedge against inflation with gold from
birch gold because the government is
sabotaging the value of the us dollar in
both the short and the long term birch
gold will help you convert an eligible
ira or 401k into an ira backed by real
gold that is peace of mind and that's
why i am a birch gold customer with
thousands of satisfied customers in a
plus rating with the better business
bureau you can trust birch gold to
protect your savings text ben to 98 98
98 to get a free information kit on gold
and when you buy before the end of the
month birch gold will send you a signed
copy of my newest book the authoritarian
moment text ben298 9898 get your free
information kit right now get started
and again when you buy before the end of
the month you get a free signed copy of
my newest book the authoritarian moment
alrighty so folks
year one of the biden administration is
now in the books
one year ago the president of the united
states was inaugurated he was handed a
working vaccine
he was handed a distribution plan for
that he was handed peace in the middle
east he was handed a fairly stable
situation in afghanistan he was handed a
russia and chinese
move that had been largely blocked
russia and china were at least somewhat
stagnant
and all of this
was really easy like if you go back and
you listen to my predictions for joe
biden here's what i said when he was
inaugurated i said that for the first
two years he'd have a pretty easy time
of it because the economy was going in
going to go into a natural recovery we
had had an artificial coma for the
economy we were already coming out of it
by q4 of 2020 and certainly 2021 was
going to be a massive boom year followed
by 2022 which would also be a massive
boom year and almost nothing joe biden
could do could stop that well wrong i
was it turns out that joe biden could in
fact stop that joe biden was handed
peace in the middle east and i said i'm
not sure how he can really screw that up
because it's not like the iranians are
on the verge of signing a deal with the
united states how can you screw that up
well he has somehow
managed to screw that up as well i i
said you know joe biden
even joe biden isn't stupid enough
to be weak with china and russia i mean
at least joe biden is going to be
somewhat
yeah
so here is the thing joe biden has had
the worst first year of any president in
american history
any president in american history there
are only two exceptions william henry
harrison because he was dead after 40
days because he went out in the rain and
then got pneumonia and died and james
garfield was shot to death those are the
only two dudes who had a worse time of
it than joe biden in his first year
there are other presidents who have had
bad first years
don't get me wrong herbert hoover was
hit with the great depression in 1929
and then his response was was bad but
that was an extraneous circumstance that
impacted his presidency that was
something unexpected
right that was a circumstance that sort
of fell on him same thing with abraham
lincoln abraham lincoln's first year
half the country seceded that really
wasn't because of abraham lincoln that
wasn't his fault he was handed a really
bad situation
year one of the george w bush
administration gets september 11th
joe biden hasn't had any of those things
joe biden was handed peace joe biden was
handed a track a natural track to
prosperity all he had to do was be what
he already was which was a dead person
that's all he had to do ironically if
joe biden had william henry harrison's
first year he'd still be a popular
president
because joe biden was elected to be not
alive he was elected to be
a
house plant as i say a barely alive
thing that doesn't speak very much and
blocks the water stains that's pretty
much all he was there to do president
house plan and somehow he's managed to
blow this in historic fashion it is the
greatest self-inflicted wound i have
ever seen a president commit
and that includes president trump if
president trump spent several years
completely undermining the
accomplishments of his own
administration because he couldn't stop
his fingers from hitting buttons on
twitter okay but here's the thing trump
was unpopular the day he came into
office joe biden was wildly popular when
he came into office and somehow joe
biden has managed to make himself an
extraordinarily unpopular president to
the point where quinnipiac polls yeah
they're slight outliers but only slight
have them in the low 30s
i mean look at let's look at the
presidential approval ratings for for
example donald trump okay we'll use
trump
as the contrast point because of course
according to the left trump was the
worst in america
okay so
right from the outset donald trump did
not have one day of his presidency where
he was in the black in his approval
rating he did not have one net positive
day
in his presidency where he was on top in
the approval rating
in day one
day one he was almost even is it like 45
positive 45
negative and immediately within like the
first couple of weeks he had shifted to
49 negative
and like 46 positive
and then he just kind of stayed there
for his entire presidency
he had some ups he had some nouns
when it was really bad he had up to 58
of people disliking him and and 39 of
people liking him
but by the end of his first year he was
writing about 54 percent disapproval and
42 percent approval that's he's
underwater by 10 points 12 points by the
end of his by the end of his first year
and now here is joe biden's approval
rating this is unbelievable it really is
it's incredible
so he starts off with a 55 56 approval
rating only 36 percent of americans say
they disapprove of joe biden
and pretty quickly you start to see
these lines narrow
right but but they're not narrowing to
the point where he's anywhere near
negative territory by the time you hit
in the end of july
he's he's kind of around 45 disapproved
but he's still got 51 percent approval
rating
there's a swing of about three points on
average like a a mild decrease in his
approval rating and then comes
afghanistan
which is when the president of the
united states decides to shoot his
entire administration directly in the
face and when i say shoot his
administration in the face what i really
mean is get 13 american service people
killed abandoned 19 million women to to
abject sex slavery and allow
a bunch of eighth century barbarian
cavemen to overrun a country and take
all of america's leftover military
equipment
it turns out americans don't like that
sort of thing and so joe biden's
disapproval rating now spikes
into the into the plurality position of
the american people
by the time you hit september which is
exactly when this happens right the end
of august the the beginning of support
you see this giant spike in the
disapproval rating
over the course of late august by the
time you hit the beginning of september
joe biden is now at 48 disapproved and
48 and 48 approved
and then it just gets worse it just
keeps getting worse and worse and worse
for joe biden so this is the thing
donald trump started off bad and he
ended bad in terms of the disapproval
rating joe biden
started off really popular
and is really really unpopular right now
because he's crappy at this job he is
just garbage at this job as barack obama
once famously stated don't underestimate
joe's ability to f things up
don't underestimate it again
look back at the trump chart for just
one moment because the swing is what
matters here
the swing here is from about 45 percent
approved
and 45 disapproved to 52 disapprove okay
so that is about a
seven point swing right 45 to 52 over
the course of year one a seven point
swing in the negative direction for
president trump over the course of year
one now look again at the joe biden
chart okay this joe biden chart shows a
swing from 56 percent approved to 42 a
14 point negative swing
okay so trump got seven points less
popular over the course of his first
year joe biden got 14
less popular over the course of his
first year
that's how bad this guy is at this
he's just awful
and we're going to go through where
things stand year one of the abiding and
all of this is self-inflicted guys this
is all because joe biden is an
incompetent buffoon it's because as nate
silver suggests it's not that joe biden
was ever a moderate it's just that joe
biden was always dead center of the
democratic party and the democratic
party has gone completely nuts the
democratic party's entire theory of
politics is that everything was crazy
because of just trump if it weren't for
trump we'd be back to normal right trump
was insane and it was all about the the
affect it was all about the tweeting and
all about the attitude and all about the
crazy jokes and all about the bleeding
from whatever and all that kind of stuff
okay and and this led them to believe
that so long as the president of the
united states
didn't say things like that they could
do anything they wanted and people would
just be like well i guess things are
still sane
no
wrong it turns out there are two forms
of political crazy one form of political
crazy is going out there and ripping on
mexican judges for no reason and that's
kind of like
mildly political crazy because most
people are just like that's you know
that's kind of nutty behavior but it has
no impact on my life then there's true
political craziness which is boys should
be girls and girls should be boys
everybody who disagrees with me wants
jim crow
what if we pour money onto a gasoline
fire of inflation and what if we just
surrender to china and russia
they in turn what if we just give
afghanistan to the top let's just give
it to them for no reason
here
have afghanistan that's a form of crazy
that has real impact on people's lives
as opposed to you know the bad tweets
and democrats failed to recognize that
they thought so long as they slapped a
kindly old face
on an insane agenda everything would be
fine rongo and it turns out all that
happens is that people begin to realize
that the kindly old face ain't so kindly
when the agenda is really nefarious
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about a simple
fact you need life insurance let's say
tomorrow there were to be an alien
invasion and you knew it was coming
because a long time ago in the past you
were just out on your farm and you've
been abducted by aliens so you've been
warning everybody you knew for 20 years
right you had forethought you had
foresight you knew this was going to
happen
and so you were called once more into
battle because you'd once been in the
air force and um you've been discharged
and you got into your rickety biplane
and as you were flying directly up into
the heart of one of the giant invader
spaceships it occurred to you man i knew
about this 20 years in advance but i
didn't buy life insurance that was a
real mistake should have gone over to
policy genius head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro answer a few
questions about yourself in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need compare personalized
quotes to find your best price you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
their license experts will help you
understand your options and apply for a
policy the policy junior's team works
for you not the insurance companies you
can trust them to offer unbiased help
and advocate for you every step until
you are covered policy genius does not
add on extra fees policy genius doesn't
sell your information to third parties
policy genius has thousands of five-star
reviews across google and trustpilot and
since 2014 they've helped over 30
million people shop for insurance and
placed 120 billion dollars in coverage
head on over to
policygenius.com get your free life
insurance quotes see how much you could
save today okay so
joe biden is is having a terrible
terrible first year mark these and has a
very good column over at the washington
post all about this he says this is the
lived reality millions of americans are
facing a year after a year of biden's
presidency inflation has reached a
40-year high and we have a massive labor
shortage with more than 10 million
unfilled jobs biden signed a partisan
1.9 trillion covered relief bill in
march and when omicron arrived there
weren't enough coronavirus tests or
therapeutics schools are closing again
emergency room visits for suspected
suicide attempts by adolescent girls
have jumped 51 from 2019 to 2021. at
least 12 major cities broke annual
homicide records in 2021. we are
experiencing the worst border crisis in
american history and a surge of deadly
fentanyl crossing the southern border
has helped fuel an increase of 30
percent in overdose deaths in the past
year the disastrous retreat from
afghanistan projected weakness on the
world stage and emboldened russia to
amass troops along its border with
ukraine putting us on the knife's edge
of a land war in europe and while biden
promised in his inaugural address to put
his whole soul into uniting the country
he just gave a speech comparing millions
of americans to segregationists and
traitors
yeah that's that's a pretty
bad record that's a pretty bad record
now biden is trying to happy talk his
way through this thing
he's doing the obama routine which is
the people just don't understand him
this is obama's routine every time he
did something on pop you'd be like well
i just didn't explain it well enough the
american people if they understood what
i was doing they would love it and the
american me like no we we understand
just what you were doing and we do not
love it as it turns out
and then you get the same routine from
biden well if i just
ah come on you know
you know man
if you could help me explain these
policies then travel to tables
come on up here
kamala oh
yeah this is
that's going to work but even elizabeth
warren who is full-fledged terrible at
this
the the chief
biden critic from the left in the senate
even elizabeth warren
how bad is she she she um
even she can't answer if joe biden is up
to the job she's asked like is joe biden
up to the job up for the job and she had
reservations
let me ask you about 2024 do you believe
that president biden is up for the job
president biden's running for reelection
i expect to support him
his approval ratings are some of the
lowest that they've been for a very long
time i i understand that but remember
we've just finished the first quarter
we're just starting into the second
quarter here so we've got a lot of time
a lot of work in front of us i love that
like so do you think he's up to the
job's like well he is running for
reelection like says he is he good at
this he's like well
there's time and time exists
i like how they flash his approval
rating on the screen though according to
that cbs news poll by the way he's gone
from 61 approval to 44
yeah those are not good numbers gang
there's a really bad number so the good
news is the white house
has found a reason to pivot they want a
pivot pivot pivot pivot they're like
ross in the stairwell with the couch
pivot we have to pivot
according to nbc news white house plots
public reset as biden's agenda fails i
love this i love it so much every time
the newspaper start talking about how a
politician needs to reset how a
politician needs to re-jigger their
comms what they really mean is this
politician is super bad at it this is
what you hear from kamala harris's team
every 20 minutes
like almost on the dot they just set a
timer on their watch like it's been 20
minutes time to reset kamala's calm
strategy and kamala's over in the corner
saying uh it is it is time to
do what we have always done in
time is
with a clock
and her team's like okay it's been 20
minutes time to reset that comms she's
over there
guys it isn't the comms you're bad at
this it's not yours it's not your
communication strategy it's that your
policies suck they're bad
they're bad
i mean joe biden's entire comm strategy
during his campaign was what if i sit in
a basement and eat oatmeal and watch
matlock and he won okay so like it's not
about the comms it's about you sucking
at this
i'm not sure you could be worse at this
if you tried to be bad at it it's
incredible
we'll get to that that
we'll get to that story in a second
about the the try the attempted
rejiggering of the biden's calm strategy
first
let us talk about your comfort level in
your home so i've already talked to you
many many times about the helix sleep
mattress which i rely upon each and
every night in order to refresh me for
the next day but now helix has gone
beyond the boudoir they've started
making sofas they just launched a new
company it's called all form they're
making premium customizable sofas and
chairs shipped directly to your door so
what makes an all form sofa really cool
well for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you can pick the
fabric it is spill stain scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs sofa size and shape make sure
it is perfect for you and your home i
have an all form sofa sitting directly
in my home right now i got one for my
parents as well they've got arm shares
they got love seats all the way up to an
eight-seat sectional there's something
for everyone i've got that three-seat
sofa with the chase in the sand color
with espresso legs it's super
comfortable
it is my preferred couch for napping if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky well you don't need
to worry because you have 100 days to
decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund they also have a
forever warranty literally for all time
all form is offering 20 off all orders
for our listeners at
allform.com to find your perfect sofa
check out
allform.com
go check them out right now okay so
according to nbc news it's time for a
reset it's a reset guys
biden's reset plan senior administration
official said is to make his
conversations with members of congress
less of a public priority and to
emphasize spending more time
communicating directly with americans
yeah that's going to go well because
he's done a great job of that so far you
know every week he gets on your tv and
falls asleep he gets on your tv like uh
covert is then the unboxed are let's
let's hit them with my with my walker
i'm gonna hit them with my work
and americans like that's not he didn't
that's that's not good he said well if
you don't you don't like that here i am
on your tv again and i think that you
want to re-enslave black people and
answer
that nope not doing it
not that that's not helping joe
who what if i what if i say that that
you guys are basically
no this isn't going to work joe biden is
a bad communicator he's very very bad at
this
this is the part that's so funny is
every he's a master communicator the
dude ran for president 83 times he lost
all of the times the only reason anyone
even knows joe biden's name right now
other than as the the foolish
plagiaristic senator who had to drop out
of a presidential race once and got
shellacked every other time he ran and
was a senator from a state that is
mainly run by credit card companies
the only reason anyone has ever heard of
joe biden is because barack obama needed
a buffoonish old white man to be his
vice president now sometimes i say that
that kamala harris was an affirmative
action pick because she was because joe
biden said i need a black woman joe
biden was also an affirmative action
pick barack obama was like what if i
just take a stayed old white man so that
i look moderate
that was pretty much his agenda
and joe biden continued to fail upward
the only reason that joe biden is
president right now is because barack
obama picked him for his vice president
and then
his main competition in a democratic
primary was a senile old communist
and then his main competition in the
presidential race
was a guy who just
blurred all over twitter every two
minutes like that that is the only
reason that this idiot is president of
the united states and like what if he
talked more to the american you go for
it man put him on the tvs every day more
of him he does a spectacular job
first rule of holes stop digging but joe
biden is out there with a spade digging
just all the way to china
there is a recognition we need to change
the dynamic a senior administration
official told nbc news adding that biden
has told aids and lawmakers he intends
to make the shift
there's nothing that joe biden does
better than
sticking and moving that's what he's
great at part of the goal is to shed the
growing image that biden is approaching
the presidency like a member of the
senate where he spent more than three
decades he's mindful he doesn't want to
send the message his role is to be
legislator-in-chief another senior
administration official said biden's
advisors are looking at a variety of
ways for him to engage more with
americans officials said there's no
agreement yet about what the
alternatives might entail he can only
eat ice cream so many times
he can only run naked after his dog from
the shower like so many times
while there is unity among advisors
about having biden talk to more people
directly another official said there's
no agreement about whether the effort
will work no there is it's not going to
work i'm just going to put it it's not
going to work
spoiler alert joe biden talking to
humans not anything that works
changing a white house strategy to
engage more directly with americans is
an evergreen reset plan that has been
activated by previous presidents who
have found themselves in politically
precarious moments for biden that moment
has arrived earlier than his team
expected after early momentum from his
sweeping safety net bill
presidential historian michael buschloss
said oftentimes in modern history when a
president has frustrations and drops in
the polls the president will say it's
now time for me to talk over the heads
of the elites and talk directly to the
people to convince them that what i'm
trying to do is right
yeah the problem is that biden can't
talk anymore he just grunts and makes
noises
why is it in your machine
biden has struggled to gain his footing
on the coronavirus pandemic which he
promised to get under control and
ultimately defeat he's also been
hampered by the collapse of bill back
better while some of biden's aides have
expressed concern
they're very concerned that he is
seemingly bogged down at the white house
giving too many one-dimensional speeches
from washington instead of showcasing
what they see as his greatest political
strength empathy and an ability to
connect with ordinary americans that is
gone he blew it up it's over for him
yeah this is why he's not going to
recover the reason he's not going to
recover is because once you blow the
empathy line it ain't coming back once
it has been revealed that you care less
about american soldiers dying in
afghanistan then you reaching a pull-out
by an arbitrary date so that you can
celebrate yourself as some sort of grand
peacemaker which is what happened in
afghanistan that ain't coming back
joe biden captain empathy was always
bullcrap but it certainly is not coming
back now and when he started defending
his action in afghanistan
and and dead service members in
afghanistan by citing the fact that his
son died of brain cancer like no none of
that works and it ain't coming back and
it is over for him
he's still got to be president for three
years but that guy is a lame duck right
now
and by the way that lame duckery has
consequences as it turns out
he is failing on every single front
remember joe biden and barack obama in
2012 suggested when mitt romney said
that the greatest geopolitical threat
the united states faced was russia joe
biden said that the 1980s called and
they wanted their foreign policy back
well now russia is about to invade
ukraine russia has a hundred thousand
troops on the borders of ukraine they're
openly threatening ukraine and joe
biden's own white house is like yeah
they couldn't invade at any moment we
really have no plans
do you think the threat of invasion is
getting higher or lower
well i think as i noted a few minutes
ago we believe we're now at a stage
where russia could at any point launch
an attack on ukraine
i would say that's more stark than we
have been
more so well i mean now that you've said
it problem solved right guys tony
blinken is being sent to meet his
russian counterpart as the white house
is warning that moscow could attack
ukraine at any point and given anthony
blinken's stellar record of being
terrible at literally everything he
touches i'm sure this will end really
really well i'm sure he's gonna do a
great job
yeah i'm you know not so much not too
much again every wound that this
administration is suffering from is a
wound they inflicted themselves they
made all this happen
this is not again some sort of
extraneous circumstance that crashed
down upon their heads like the civil war
upon lincoln or like the great
depression on herbert hoover every
single thing that has happened right now
that is damaging this administration is
the fault of this administration it's
unprecedented it really is incredible
we'll get to more of it in just one
second first are you spending too much
money on gas of course you are why well
because joe biden is the president of
the united states and everything he
touches turns to crap
well here is the thing there is an
incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about get upside my
listeners are making up 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download that free get upside
app in the app store or google play
right now use promo code shapiro get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash back
don't pay full price at the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank of gas some
people who drive a lot are making as
much as two to three hundred bucks a
year in cash back there is no catch the
cash back gets added directly to your
account you can cash out anytime to your
bank account paypal or an egift card for
amazon and other brands just download
that free get upside app use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
that is promo code shapiro get that free
get upside app and turn the situation of
crap to app with get that free get
upside app yeah i know it was clever
right use promo code shapiro get up to
50 cents per gallon cash back on that
first tank when you get that free get
upside app and use promo code shapiro
okay so tony blinken the greatest of all
secretaries of state has now been
deployed over to talk with the russians
according to the washington post
secretary of state lincoln will meet
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
in geneva on friday in an effort to
resolve the standoff over ukraine with
u.s officials warning a russian invasion
could be imminent the meeting will
follow a week of intense diplomacy as
the top u.s diplomat heads to ukraine
and germany for discussions on the
crisis the state department said adding
urgency to lincoln's talks is russia's
fresh deployment of troops to belarus to
conduct major military exercises that
will further strengthen the number of
russian forces along ukraine's border
the true movements coupled with
statements from moscow that it was
unsatisfied with meetings held with the
united states european and nato
officials last week have had some
officials in washington fearing the
worst
despite the troubling developments a
senior state department official said
the meeting between lincoln and lavrov
in the swiss city indicated that
diplomacy is not dead
the official said we are prepared to
continue to engage with russia on
security issues in a meaningful
reciprocal dialogue we'll see this
friday if russia prepares to do the same
the official declined to say if the u.s
or russia first proposed the meeting the
reason you declined is because the
answer is the united states
and the answer is that the united states
is going hand in hand to the russians to
say what can we do to prevent you from
simply walking into ukraine see here's
the thing maybe we'll have some sort of
response to russia invading ukraine but
the reason russia is invading ukraine is
because when you surrender on the world
stage to you know a bunch of barbarians
from the 8th century
all of your political opponents look at
you and go hey maybe we should do
something too
hilariously enough we still have members
of the biden administration defending
the administration's activities in
afghanistan u.n ambassador linda thomas
greenfield
she still thinks that we fix things in
afghanistan which is kind of incredible
considering that you know the entire
country is now under the purview of a of
a massive terror group
we ended a 20-year war the president
committed to doing that
uh and he followed through on that
commitment it was a challenging
withdrawal
but i can tell you that i have met with
our afghan allies who are here in the
u.s including just as recently as
yesterday and people are proud of of the
support that the u.s government has
provided to them and proud of
their
uh relationship with uh with the u.s
government uh this was a situation uh
that we found and the president fixed it
so now everybody in the binding
administration is just singing songs
from south pacific keep on happy talking
happy talk talk about things you like to
do i mean my goodness
just the happy talk
it was a wild success guys and if they
say it over and over enough then
probably you'll believe it meanwhile
china russia and iran are teaming up for
joint naval exercises so this is going
great
according to newsweek russia has said it
will take part in joint naval exercises
with both china and iran as scrutiny
grows over moscow's military maneuvers
following a buildup of troops next to
the ukrainian border
the announcement comes only days after
moscow said it would conduct a snap
combat readiness inspection of its
troops in the russian far east amid
growing alarm in world capitals over the
prospect of an invasion of ukraine so
things are going great on foreign policy
meanwhile joe biden is completely
failing on covet like utterly and
completely failing on covet now the
reason that he's failing on covet is
because no one succeeds on kobit
what i mean by this is the only people
who succeed on covet are the people who
protect the most vulnerable and leave
everybody else alone and you know who's
starting to pick up on this everyone
else on earth literally all of them
so for example boris johnson of the uk
said earlier this morning quote from
tomorrow we will no longer acquire face
masks in classrooms and the department
for education will shortly remove
national guidance on their use in
communal areas by saying it's over go
back to your lives that is boris johnson
in the uk meanwhile in israel which has
been hyperactive on covet right
everybody in israel is supposed to get
87 straight shots until the majority of
their body tissue is composed of the
vaccine
now they're leading vaccine expert he's
like yeah you know what we're not doing
that anymore he says the green pass
vaccine passport is no longer relevant
in the omicron area and should be phased
out meanwhile you've got washington d.c
lockdown and gensake telling you you
should slap an n95 on your child
professor surreal cohen is the head of
immunology at barilon university he's a
member of the advisory committee for
vaccines for the israeli government
he says that he was surprised and
disappointed that the vaccines did not
prevent transmission as they'd
originally hoped
he apologized for closing schools
he says that widespread infection is now
an inevitable part of future immunity he
says we're not sure shooting for hurt
immunity that is just the result of the
simple fact that omicron is going to hit
everybody and he says that omicron has
now accelerated the pandemic into the
endemic phase in which coveted will be
like the flu
okay so all over the world people are
starting to realize that you got to let
this go but biden won't let it go it
keeps trying to grip it harder
okay
so so here is the washington post
reporting on biden's first year quote a
year ago biden unveiled a 200-page plan
to defeat covet he has struggled to
deliver on some key promises boy howdy
ain't that an underestimation of how
badly he has failed
the president declared in its pandemic
strategy released january 21 2021
businesses are closing hospitals are
full families are saying goodbye to
their loved ones remotely our nation
continues to experience the darkest days
of the pandemic yet after a period when
biden's vaccination focus appeared to be
paying off many of those problems have
roared back as the delta variants and
then omicron tour across the country
once again doctors and nurses are
pleading for relief as hospitalization
set new daily records and more
facilities move to ration care by the
way many of these facilities are
rationing care specifically because of
things like the joe biden vax mandate
which has taken a crapload of doctors
and nurses offline
and the simple fact is that the number
of hospitalizations in the united states
right now has been fairly steady
it really has not risen supremely
dramatically in terms of long-term
hospitalizations in fact people who are
going to the hospital with omicron very
often they're not going because of
omicron they're going because they broke
their leg and they were tested from a
crime they have it and they're
asymptomatic
and even if they are going for omicron
the average hospital stays now down from
like four days to 1.6 days
omicron is way less severe thank god
than delta is
but
everybody on the left is unhappy with
biden for not doing enough and everybody
on the right is unhappy with biden
because he just won't let this thing go
right the washington post says as he
prepared to take office biden oversaw a
200-page pandemic plan that promised to
restore trust in the federal government
protect essential workers and slow
coveted spread but as president he has
struggled to execute key parts of it
page 59 promised predictable and robust
federal purchasing of cova test kits
wrong page 81 pledged to support schools
in implementing covet 19 screening
testing wrong page 103 vowed to ensure
patient safety in nursing homes by
boosting staffing and vaccinations wrong
so here's the bottom line jude has
failed and everybody knows that he has
failed
so how is he dealing with this he's
planning to give you a free n95
yeah
yeah yay yay is that really really with
omicron that's your plan
your plan is what the government should
have done in like may of 2020.
this is what the government should have
done in may 2020 by the way the
government should have sent to everybody
in n95 in may of 2020 april 2020 like as
soon as humanly possible and they should
have said if you feel that you are at
risk
then you should wear an n95 and if you
are young and you are healthy you
probably shouldn't
that's what sweden did
and everything was okay okay like the
the big mistake in sweden is that they
didn't shield the elderly enough
but now they're now they're sending 400
million
non-surgical n95s to people from the
strategic national stockpile how how's
this going to be effective
okay no one thinks this is going to be
effective is the reality
and so this has reduced the the even
democrats are now throwing biden under
the bus on this stuff here's democrat
tim ryan from ohio and moderate
democrats realize that 2022 is going to
be an anti-biden wave year and so some
of them are starting to
dissociate from from biden they're like
i'm going to stand all they're like
homer simpson with the bush they're just
kind of drawing back into the bush away
from biden here is here's tim ryan
we need the president we need the
administration uh to lead the way
they're they're in charge the buck stops
there there's no doubt about that and
and we need to get things done we're not
doing good enough we're two years into
this thing and i think that the
frustration level is getting to people
here and do you blame president biden
for that frustration
well i mean the president is the
president and there's no question that
he bears some responsibility for it
yeah i i think maybe just just a little
bit the media for their part they're
they're continuing to try to spin on
behalf of biden it's just failing okay
joe biden's actual job approval rating
according to gallup today dropped again
to 40 so he is now 16 points under one
according to gallup on the one year
anniversary of his inauguration it's
just that
amazing amazing stuff here so it's the
media trying to do their best to spin
for for biden still and so here is don
lemon
ever the good soldier on behalf of the
biden administration i have to say don
lemon is not a smart human wow is he not
a smart human
when i tell people i said you know
they'll say well i've been doing my own
research and uh last week i was in miami
i said how did you get to miami i flew
that's science
so if you don't believe in science why
didn't you walk
right
it's well because i can't always follow
the science that's the reason that
you're here that's the reason that you
don't have polio that's reason we don't
see polio cases that's the reason why we
don't see smallpox cases is because your
parents had the wherewithal and the
sense to get you vaccinated as a child
so i don't told that they had to
that you had to because what we have to
start doing things for the greater good
of society and not for idiots who to
think that they can do their own
research you can't do your own research
man if you did your own research would
you get on a plane man would you get a
i would because you know what doesn't
happen with the plane okay let's say
that planes
they took off and like every 200 miles
or so they broke down and you had to get
on a new plane
let's say that you got on a plane and
some of those planes just kind of
crashed randomly and you're like why i
don't understand what if they told you
that every time you took a plane it was
going to be a one
a non-stop all the way across country
but as it turns out it ran out of gas
every 150 miles
would you would you be a little more
skeptical about maybe maybe you would
take a train maybe you might consider
taking a drink
by the way joe
don lemon
speaking about science and planes he has
he has picked a poor example don lemon
i'm old enough to remember when you
suggested that maybe a plane was eaten
by a black hole on national television
whether it was hijacking or terrorism or
mechanical failure or pilot error but
what if there's something fully that we
don't really understand a lot of people
have been asking about that about black
holes and on and on and on and all of
these conspiracy theories let's look at
this uh noah says what else can you
think about black hole bermuda triangle
and then deji says huh just like the
movie lost and of course it's also
they're also referencing the twilight
zone which has a very similar plot
that's what people are saying i know
it's preposterous but is it preposterous
you think mary it's preposterous but is
it preposterous that a black hole might
have eaten a plane because science
science captain science over here
yeah
these are when you're relegated to
having don lemon defend you you have a
real problem on your hands okay in one
second we'll get to joe biden's failures
on the economy because we've talked
about foreign policy and we've talked
about coven we'll get to the economy in
just one second because it just keeps
getting worse for joe biden first let's
talk about a simple fact in many places
you just need homeowners insurance right
and you need homeowners insurance
because you're afraid that a fire a
flood or a burglary could destroy you
financially there's another major crime
that your homeowner's insurance does not
cover however this is called home title
fraud the fbi calls title fraud one of
the fastest growing crimes that can ruin
you financially that is the reason you
need home title lock so here's what
happens when title fraud occurs well a
criminal forges your signature on
documents stating you sold your home to
him then he takes out a loan against
your home and leaves you with the
payments they'll spend a fortune in
legal fees trying to prove you didn't
commit fraud home title lock puts a
barrier around your home title the
instant they detect anyone from a cyber
thief to a renter to a relative trying
to forge their way onto your home title
they help shut it down cold go to home
title lock dot com register your
addresses see if you're already a victim
and then enter radio for your 60 day
money back guarantee that's code radio
at home title lock.com again home title
lock.com protect yourself from a crime
that really goes after your most
valuable asset the most expensive thing
you own is undoubtedly your home don't
let anybody access the value in that
home go to hometitlelock.com right now
and use code radio for a 60-day
money-back guarantee alrighty we'll get
to more on this in just one moment first
guys the first gathering from my book
club kicks off tomorrow 8 pm eastern 7
00 pm central unless you're a very fast
reader you should probably already have
joined the book club at third
thursdaybookclub.com and signed up as a
daily wire member to get my notes and
guide for tomorrow's discussion or
perhaps you can just use my notes and
guide as a cheat sheet if you want to
sign up like right now january's book of
choices george orwell's fantastic
dystopian novel 1984 of course that is
our first book and tomorrow we'll also
announce what we're doing for our second
book so remember sign up for the book
club at third thursdaybookclub.com
dailywire members get my full notes and
guide to each month's book then on the
third thursday of each month i will join
all access members online for an
in-depth lecture and discussion where
you can ask me questions directly right
now get 25 off a daily wire membership
with code 1984 over at dailywire.com
subscribe i can't wait to hang out and
discuss orwell with you i love reading
and if you had made yourself a new
year's resolution to read more this year
you need to join the book club head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe he's
code 1984 for your all-access membership
and you can hang with me and the third
thursday book club tomorrow 8 p.m
eastern 7 pm central you are listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so you're one of the biden presidency a
giant fail foreign policy fail covid
fail economy massive fail how do you
know that the economy is is massively
failing when cnn is now running pieces
titled should the government control the
price of food and gas so we went from
inflation doesn't exist it's all in your
mind you shouldn't worry about it at all
it has been a problem in america for 40
years to well inflation is happening but
it's transitory it'll go away soon
to build back better is probably going
to help the inflation to well inflation
isn't transitory and it's here but it's
good because it just it demonstrates how
much demand there is so inflation is
actually a positive and we should view
it that way to what if the government
actually just controls prices now
because inflation is really bad and
scary
it's amazing that evolution right we
went all the way from inflation is not
happening to inflation is permanent and
also the government should control food
and gas prices like that that's a pretty
wild transition is it not according to
cnn people are paying a lot more for
food gas cars and services inflation
isn't over yet as pandemic continues to
distort the economy so should
governments consider setting the price
of essential goods
it's been done before typically during
times of crisis but for most mainstream
economists the answer to this is a
resounding no limiting how much
companies can charge will distort
markets causing shortages and
exacerbating supply chain problems while
only temporarily reducing inflation well
yeah
duh
just stop seriously said austin goolsbee
a professor at the university of chicago
yeah i mean
just stop seriously is the best response
that is a good response by austin
goolsbee golsby previously served as
chairman of the council of economic
advisors under obama
the attitude toward price controls
appears to be similar in washington
where policymakers have shown little
enthusiasm for even targeted or
temporary measures despite growing
pressure on middle-class families that
feel the pain of price increases more
than the rich still says cnn with annual
inflation running at a four-decade high
of seven percent price controls could
feature in future debates over how to
reduce prices see here's the thing when
you create price controls
you are you are being an idiot because a
price control does not increase the
manufacturing it doesn't actually mean
that there is more of the product it
just means that there is more demand for
less of a product
that's all that happens it radically
distorts markets
i i love that that cnn then tries to
debunk this like economists who are
skeptical of price controls often point
to basic economic concepts
yes that
they argue that capping prices
encourages companies to produce less of
the product while making it more
attractive to consumers supply goes down
demand goes up yes but that doesn't stop
governments around the world from
resorting to price controls
there's plenty of precedent for price
controls in the us like cnn is now
actively arguing on behalf of price
controls the single most ridiculous
encounter productive economic policy
that any government can take and look at
rent control which radically reduces the
amount of supply in housing also the
quality of housing leads landlords to
simply abandon things
and leads to housing shortages
control of prices and wages is a
terrible terrible idea but when you box
yourself into a corner what exactly are
you supposed to do
meanwhile joe biden is trying to
politicize the fed
according to jeb hensarling writing for
the wall street journal during federal
reserve chairman jerome's pal
reconfirmation hearing last week there
was an understandable focus on inflation
led by republican senator pat toomey
several senators expressed concern that
politicization of the fed is hampering
its effectiveness in dealing with
inflation and could lead to an erosion
of monetary policy independence if such
concerns are left unaddressed the
american economy will suffer
congress should resist the temptation to
use the fed to advance social policy or
fund its favorite programs off-budget in
turn the fed should halt its mission
creep into fiscal policy and stay out of
unrelated partisan congressional debate
however
the fed has become thoroughly ensconced
in fiscal policy specific credit
specifically credit policy by
backstopping practically every credit
market in the united states
and now the democrats wish to make this
worse
and the fed wishes to thoroughly
politicize the fed
by basically declaring that all monetary
policy is emergency policy
right the the fed is losing its
independence to the executive branch and
that is a problem and joe biden wants
that problem right i mean
he wants more control his solution for
joe biden to a lack of ability is more
control
meanwhile joe biden can't even control
his own party right so the the internal
democratic war continues a pace
so yesterday joe biden joe biden is now
seeing that the american public hate his
gods and are not interested in his party
controlling congress his new answer is
just a plain old conspiracy theory
if we lose it's because they rigged the
elections now again it is incredible to
me and we have spent
a couple of years here talking about how
donald trump perverted american
elections and he's undermining faith in
american elections meanwhile the
president of the united states is
literally going around
to places like georgia and saying that
if votes take place under current rules
it will have been rigged
that any election procedure that takes
place in a republican state can
effectively be questioned and thrown out
because the procedures are rigged
what he is saying is no different than
anything trump said except he has even
less evidence of voter suppression than
trump out of election fraud and yet the
media are just on like this is what joe
biden tweeted yesterday he tweeted this
jim crow 2.0 is about two insidious
things voter suppression
and election subversion
it's about making it harder to vote who
gets to count to vote and whether your
vote counts at all
we have to pass the freedom to vote act
and john lewis voting rights and rounds
win
okay so um jim crow 2.0 so he's
immediately saying
that every election security law in
america is about preventing black people
promoting it's jim crow 2.0 he says it's
about voter suppression name the voter
who has been suppressed mr president a
voter one just one who's been suppressed
who's been prevented from voting in the
united states
name a human one it shouldn't be hard
you're saying it's happening millions
and millions and millions of times over
in republican states right now name them
name one you can't because it's a lie
elections he's saying that
not only are you preventing people from
voting you are then subverting elections
by literally changing the counts right
he's saying who gets to count the vote
is the real question
right you're changing he's accusing
republicans of not only rigging who gets
to vote but then rigging how the votes
are actually counted
that is a full-fledged conspiracy theory
it's madness
okay so
he's failed on every front and so his
new solution is to suggest that votes
are being stolen in the united states
and that everyone who opposes him is a
vicious racist in favor of jim crow
meanwhile he's trying out jen saki to
explain that you know when he says that
you love segregation and that you're
with bull connor that's not divisive
that's just the truth
the president delivered a powerful
speech about uh the protection of
people's fundamental rights in this in
this country which is their right to
vote the right to
to vote for anyone they choose whether
it is him or someone else it was not a
partisan speech it was intended to lay
out for the public exactly what's at
stake and lay out for elected officials
what's at stake
and he stands by everything he said in
that speech
yeah i'm sure he does i'm sure he does
he's got nothing else when in doubt if
you're a democrat call everybody a
racist and the person who probably is
best placed to call everybody a racist
is an eight-year-old white man who used
to hang out with george wallace in the
senate probably that guy that one
good caller by the way he's destroying
his own party this idiot is so bad at
this he's destroying his own party right
now
he has chuck schumer up on the hill
proposing proposing a vote
on this voting rights bill this this
nonsense garbage federalization of
elections bill and he doesn't even have
full democratic support for it
joe manchin and christian cinema don't
even support it
get like like this is
crazy he's so out of control and so
incompetent at this that he's not
content with destroying his own
executive branch leadership he's
destroying his own senate majority in
real time at the behest of chuck schumer
who's simply trying to avoid a primary
from like aoc
it's unbelievable so in synopsis is this
guy a good president this guy is the
worst single president in american
history after one year
man i cannot wait to see what the next
few years bring my goodness all right
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out our newest podcast
morning wire on today's episode they
take a look at virginia governor glenn
youngkin's first week in office that
episode is available right now on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts so make sure to tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feldt executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire
on today's episode new polling shows a
dramatic shift in favor of republicans
the rise of the dei executive class and
virginia's new governor issues several
executive orders
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire